John Thompson sitting next to Kevin
Kugler and karke Clark Kellogg tootin
call tonight's national championship
game on Westwood One as he did the final
four over the weekend and John Thompson
calling us in right here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you coach Goodrich
very good still excited about this
tournament it's amazing to me all of the
game yeah it's been it has been
something else and I do want to get to
the type of play that we have seen so
far but I do want to get to that very
play first off your first blush reaction
was what a lot of people in America were
thinking which is oh my god can't
believe the ref didn't swallow his
whistle right there do you think that
that was in fact a worthy to call foul
at the end of that game absolutely not
absolutely not I didn't think so because
as you know rich during the course of a
game there's several calls that are
called common sense calls you know
that's when the first call that they
would have been a physician to say it
didn't this shot had been taken the
young man was fouled on his way down not
on his way up you know he has released
the ball you know but but it's just the
thing that bothered me most and you'll
remember back when Fred Brown threw the
ball away we were playing against North
Carolina okay you worry about the
well-being of the player afterwards and
I'm thinking to myself oh my god that
kid's got to live with that for the rest
of his life and you got three officials
out on the floor who don't call double
dribbling you know and but yet the same
token they get religious about that call
yeah I mean you're talking about Jerome
dribbling the ball off of his right leg
and then collecting it again and picking
it up and dribbling one more time there
was no call on that front right there
but there was contact in this moment in
a similar way that there was with Carson
Williams of Purdue against Tennessee
earlier on at least is there any solace
that there's been some consistency in
terms of a call like this not with me
there's no sauce you know I mean I think
two different
all games and I think the officials are
three people out there I don't know what
the solution is but I don't think events
of that significance should be
determined by officials unless it's a
bleep there's something that relates to
common sense calling true officials
don't call every file every violation
and a ballgame you don't sit down and
predetermine that which ones you don't
need to do but there's got to be
something that when you look at the
situations and the major events that
we've had in sports that we're not
discussed and officiated we're
discussing the play if it were something
of a concern why would we be discussing
officiating and not to play itself well
so you think Albarn should be playing
tonight then John well I'm not gonna say
that I'm not gonna say that because I'm
not going to take anything away from
anybody else I would say I'm more
concerned with the fact that the
officiating both of those things pretty
hard all of the teams that in this thing
have played hard my point is that the
officiating said would be the one that
makes the determination the teams do it
John Thompson who's calling the game on
Westwood one here on the Rich Eisen show
calling that game between Virginia and
Texas Tech tonight I mentioned at the
top of my broadcast that this is just
the second time that both final four
winners scored fewer than 65 points the
last time that happened is when
Georgetown and Houston took on each
other in your national championship year
of 1984 why do you think in this age of
3-point shooting that we're seeing such
tight ballgames tight defense here coach
well I think it is because you did it
right on the head
and a lot of it has to do with the tempo
that team wants to play I think when you
get involved in championship play people
become more cautious I think also when
you look at teams playing defense the
way that they do you know that the game
is not a game that we call in the
business a long game the game is
shortened sometimes by the offense in
the game I think the most significant
thing is the percentage that came shoot
more so than the score of the game
so yeah
as I just find it interesting that do we
see here do you think that teams that
lionize the three that focus their game
on taking the three trying to outscore
the opponent that we're maybe seeing
some sort of a watershed moment in
college basketball with this Final Four
with this national championship game I
don't know what the hell you're talking
about
well I'm just saying that so many teams
like shooting the three so much we're
seeing it so much in the NBA where we're
seeing everybody take threes as opposed
to twos we're seeing teams that are
focusing more on an offense that has
motion in it now we're seeing two
defensive teams just lock it down like
Texas Tech in Virginia well you're
absolutely correct and I think it
relates to the fact we've made people
think that being in the paint is boring
with the post up guys boring cutting
through the middle is boring you know in
those kinds of things and you can see
basketball all over the place at both
levels where people are relying on the
three I think caring has had a lot to do
with that because this phenomenal
shooting out outside but when you start
to play against the team particularly
like Texas Tech and even Alban is a very
good perimeter defensive player it
creates the problem if you're not
hitting if you're not making little
shots but you know I think it's exciting
you know when you see guys that are
making the threes but you know if you're
not making them what happens is what has
happened Matt Muniz a guy that made the
threes for Texas Tech coach John
Thompson here in the Rich Eisen show
against Michigan State and he is a
transfer a graduate transfer from South
Dakota Owens as well on Texas Tech is a
graduate transfer on Texas Tech so it
seems it does seem that way where I was
going with the question is the NCAA is
considering passing a rule that would
cost a team two scholarships to sign a
player like this and some folks think
that that would be too punitive for kids
like Mooney to transfer and have a
moment like this where do you stand
on that subject coach well I haven't
given a lot of thought but I don't agree
with that you know I don't agree with
the fact that because kids would
transfer and you know you obviously have
permitted them to do it by the existing
rules and and then it gets to a point
where you start to try to determine that
somebody's gaining an advantage you know
certain schools will not let you do that
you know and and in terms of their
individual admission standards you know
in in doing it but I don't know I
haven't given it that kind of thought
but right off the top is I would not
agree with that one bit I don't like the
way it looks you know I don't like the
way it looks because it puts the young
person in a position where you know if I
don't like the way I'm being coached
here I'll go here I don't like the way
I'm doing this I'll do that but you know
that's my old fuddy-duddy thinking well
I don't think it's funny duddy yeah to
be honest with you I think it's what's
fair for somebody like Mooney if he has
graduated certainly also his coach had
left South Dakota and he winds up at
Texas Tech he's got an opportunity to
win a championship and if we're doing
stuff that's supposed to be right for
kids and putting them and see positions
to succeed and there's just more and
more of a conversation these days about
how players need more freedom of
movement as if they were professionals
and they're not being paid at all I'm
wondering where you stand on that no I
disagree with that they are being paid
education education has a value and I
hate to hear people say that they're not
being paid without giving a formula as
to how you would pay them I was talking
about women you mentioned the thing with
Mooney if a guy graduates from school
and still has eligibility I'm in total
support of them doing that but I'm not
necessarily sure I feel about somebody
who every year before they have
graduated permitted to go to another
school that's where I have a problem
rich John Thompson here on the Rich
Eisen show what was your thoughts during
the tournament since the only time I've
been able fortunate to have a chance to
chat with you where Tom Izzo
on the griddle a little bit for the way
he was coaching Aaron Henry what were
your thoughts when you saw that and the
conversation that surrounded it you know
and and I think and you know you've been
around this stuff and in this business
you know a lot of times people interpret
things totally different from what the
two parties who are involved interpreted
from a perception standpoint sometimes
the things that I've done have not been
things that people were capable of
defining what I was doing and you got to
understand one thing two people refer to
players as you know they prefer to refer
to players as if we talked about kids
these players are not going to let you
do but so much to them in most instances
that they have not permitted you to do
based on knowing what you're doing Tom
Izzo as a hell of a coach Tom Izzo has
had respect to the players that he has
but when you see that out of the context
of your knowledge of what's going on you
tend to look at it and say oh isn't that
terrible isn't that terrible
you know but there's so many things that
not able to be translated and
interpreted with it you know for the
outside I win you don't you you know
that's why coaches sometimes have closed
practices you know you've been around
this stuff what goes on in practice
sometimes did I did I wouldn't want
anybody to see yeah I there's on the
show it's exactly what he said I mean
almost word-for-word there was the
player that you needed to or you
realized needed the hardest coaching the
toughest love in order to bring their
game to the fore coach well I I can't
think of one particular player but I do
know that you have to make an assessment
of those who can deal with various
aspects of your emotions you know
because the objective is to get him to
perform and to get him to realize his
abilities you don't treat everybody
worst thing in the world and when I hear
a dumb coach talk he says I treat
everybody the same way in life we don't
treat an administration and corporate
America you don't treat everybody the
same way
so there were some players that I felt
that I could be firmer with there's some
players that I felt that I couldn't be
firm but I also knew my limitations
in regards to all of those things you
know the assumptions you just crushed if
you're very strong and verbal with but
you know that as a coach I mean you know
that you could get on this guy stronger
than you can the other guy but as far as
you know going too far
you know what's too far in the players
and I can permit you you know these
aren't little six break kids these guys
are growing men you know they're not
gonna let you go but so far with them
what do you think of when you see
Patrick Ewing in your spot in your role
succeeding you as coach of Georgetown
what goes through your mind when you see
that thing is damn fool for wanting to
do it why is that a coach that's great
degree I guess that's what it takes
right we talked about you know that you
know and being around this dump I mean
it's so many ups and downs and I enjoyed
it you know I loved seeing him in a
position I think he's doing a great job
more importantly I'm glad he got the
opportunity you know after paying his
dues and being so many times under a
situation where he's been assistant
coach he didn't try to inherit it
because of his ability he went out
Patrick went out and tutored under
several good coaches to take the
profession so I'm very happy that he got
the opportunity the show that he knew
what he was doing last couple minutes
with John Thompson let's get to tonight
what happens tonight in your estimation
between these two teams
oh boy that's the question you know just
based on how the tournament's going it's
been great and been very unpredictable
but you know I've been excited in large
in Texas Tech because I had no idea
no no idea of whatsoever the degree of
difference they play I think the thing
that they're so exceptional about
they're most people to find these
defense based on the team concept which
is what it should be
individually in positions they have
people who can play great individual
defense Virginia is going to force them
to play the whole possession defensively
because they don't take bad shots and
they work the clock down during the
Virginia's a good defensive team but you
know it's hard for me to say I think
whoever adjusts to the atmosphere which
is important and then take the whole
game to adjust to it but anybody who
says you don't have the adrenaline
flowing differently and one of the most
important game to your career is just
telling a lie and I don't care how many
times you've been there when you go
there you know that this is a
significant game but you notice how I
have avoided answering your I did see
that I did hear that celebi's let me try
and get at it one other way if you could
choose one player you're coaching this
game you're or you're just creating a
team from this pool of players from
tonight who's the player you pick who's
the best one who's the number one draft
choice if you will from this team that
you would want you know that way because
of both of these teams be so so bent on
playing as a team so good is theirs
playing on the team I don't know the
answer to that I have to think about
that one here we talk after it's over
y'all can't jump okay I mean you got
culver you got your own you got hunter
but yet all those guys there could be
any of them no it could be any of them
and I don't know what I have on the team
to determine who I was born now if you
ask me that about mr. Williamson it's
very easy for me because these guys he's
got such a unique talent that he brings
to the game right you're not going to
get me in that situation I don't know
who does it then then you open that door
I'm sorry I gotta walk through it who
design remind you of that you've seen
coached coached against nobody nobody
that I've seen played before in and I
mean it this way I don't mean he's the
best player that I've never seen him
because I think that's a terrible burden
to put
a young guy but you know but his his his
talent skills I mean his quickness his
size his body size and you know his
intelligence in playing you know I have
not looked at anybody that I think at
this stage is their career demonstrated
those individual talents that he said
most of them and you know this that a
person that need to possess the variety
of skills that he has you look at a guy
who's played the game if I go back in
history with Bill Russell you know he
had one skill that could dominate the
game he had more than one skill in terms
of his ability but the dominant thing
was his defense so it doesn't
necessarily mean that if you have a
variety of skills as this young man
Williamson has that you're going to be
the best player that I've lived but he's
he's special I mean I had this then was
very excited to watch him play you got a
guy who's running out on the perimeter
blocking shots
most people block shots of other
people's players not the player that
they have regarding you know and he's
just he plays hard he competes he can
handle the ball I've never seen that
body I do with this young man is that
many anything entertain you know this
there's something players that can play
well and don't entertain this boy plays
well and also is a very pleasing and
entertaining player to watch
and sure as it was exhilarating to see
him in the tournament and I look forward
to seeing with the next level I always
enjoy our chats coach thanks for the
time
really appreciate it ok buddy thank you
I'm still looking for that player though
I think well let's just you know you
have some more time before tip and if
you change your mind you you just let me
know you know you just let me know you
just okay you two that's coach John
Thompson of Westwood one radio tonight
right here in the Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app